also wichtige entscheidungen
möglicherweise in berlin in jedem fall
aber in karlsruhe über beides kann ich
nun sprechen mit stephan thomae er ist
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion
guten tagen die hauptstadt
guten morgen herr fittkau hätte mir sie
haben ja die beschwerde der fdp gegen
die notbremse mit eingereicht da geht es
um kontakt sperren und schwule
schulschließungen hätten sie denn diese
klagen mit dem kenntnisstand von heute
auch eingereicht
jedenfalls dann wenn diese kontakt
beschränkungen diese ausgangssperren die
schulschließungen heute genauso
beschlossen würden wie sie damals im
april diesen jahres beschlossen worden
sind wenn sie erlauben kurz daran zu
erinnern es ging darum dass zwischen 22
und 5 uhr berg pauschale ausstands
beschränkungen bestanden oder kontakt
beschränkungen für mehr als eine person
ausgenommen kinder unter 14 jahren was
auch heißt dass du meine großeltern
nicht gemeinsam die familie ihre
enkelkinder besuchen dürfen sondern die
oma muss am montag kommen und der opa am
dienstag aber die zahl der kontakte wird
dadurch ja nicht reduziert das ist eine
kontakte schenkung die sinnlos ist oder
die ausgangssperren hießen ja dass jeder
am nachmittag zum einkaufen gehen muss
hingegen ist vielleicht sogar sinnvoll
gewesen wäre zur entzerrung der
einkaufszeiten und zur verkürzung der
schlangen an der supermarktkette die
einkaufszeiten zu verlängern also ich
bin nicht kategorisch gegen jegliche
sinnvollen maßnahmen aber solche
maßnahmen die es sinnlos erscheinen die
wollen natürlich weder damals noch heute
haben jetzt hört man ja aus berlin aus
der politik dass diese hofft dass es
jetzt sozusagen klare leitplanken aus
karlsruhe gibt was ist sozusagen
rechtens und was nichts was nicht geht
ihnen das auch so erwarten sie auch
solche ganz detailliert beschriebenen
vorgaben
dass sich das bundes was man sich doch
ziemlich lange zeit gelassen hat aber
gerade jetzt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
unter verzicht auf eine mündliche
verhandlung eine entscheidung heute
verkünden wird deutlich darauf hin dass
man sich sehr wohl gedanken darüber
gemacht hat welche maßnahmen auch in der
zukunft also nicht im rückblick auf den
damaligen gesetzgeberischen stand die
bundes notbremse vom april sollen in
zukunft möglich ist und das wird uns
sicherlich bei der diskussion auch eine
leitplanke sein wird eine obergrenze
markieren darüber hinaus man nicht gehen
kann aber alles darunter wird dann
jedenfalls
verfassungsrechtlich denkbar seien und
da muss ich dann die diskussion stecken
und deswegen hoffe ich mir der tat eine
gewisse leitlinie eine obergrenze
leitplanke für diskussionen die wir
nächsten tagen wochen und monaten zu
führen haben werden ja wie diese
leitplanken aussehen werden wir dann ja
gleich in rund einer viertelstunde
erfahren kommen wir zu dem anderen
wichtigen ereignis in berlin die ampel
wollte ja eigentlich dass die korona
maßnahmen eher regional verhängt werden
und die entscheidungen bei den ländern
bleiben nun gibt es heute doch ein bund
länder treffen zur möglichen
koordinierung warum haben sie ihre linie
verlassen
ich halte es weiterhin für richtig dass
wir da wo man differenzieren kann auch
differenzieren sollte warum soll in
helgoland etwas gelten was ausgelöst
wurde auch infektionsgeschehen in
berchtesgaden also wir haben eben eine
eine große fläche wir haben eine nord
süd ausdehnung des landes von rund 1000
kilometern
da kann man nicht immer alles über einen
kamm scheren nordsee zu den alpen und
vom rhein bis zur oder manchmal ist es
möglich sogar einrichtungs genauer auf
bestimmte betrieb oder einrichtungen hin
maßnahmen zu beschränken und manchmal
muss man flächig vorgehen das ist nicht
immer gleich und deswegen ist es schwer
jemanden ich verwende das beispiel noch
mal auf helgoland begreiflich zu machen
weshalb maßnahme dulden muss wenn in
berchtesgaden ausbruchsgeschehen
feststellen aber auf helgoland im
einzelfall darauf an aber herr thoma auf
helgoland werden keine fußballspiele mit
50.000 zuschauern abgehalten sollte man
da heute und in ähnlichen fällen
einheitliche regeln auf der ebene der
ministerpräsidenten mit dem kanzleramt
verabredet
also gewisse großveranstaltung wie die
von ihnen jetzt gerade angesprochenen
fußballspiele das ist nicht schon
etwashausen sich genauer ansehen muss
muss das denn sein muss ja nicht zu
geisterspielen greifen aber man kann ja
überlegen ob man einfach die zahl der
zuschauer mit abständen auch in
fußballstadien begrenzt es kommt darauf
an immer das mildeste mittel zu wählen
manche wollen immer gleich zum härtesten
mittel greifen das kann vielleicht gar
emotional noch nachvollziehen aber
rechtlich müssen wir uns das mildeste
mittel überlegen und das kann eben ein
regional beschränktes vorgehen sein oder
eben dass wir überlegen ob wir
vielleicht nicht ganze fußball spiele
sperren und zu geisterspielen machen
aber die zahl der zuschauer begrenzen
also das ist die maßgabe dass geeignete
und angemessene mittel zu ergreifen und
immer das mildeste mittel anzuwenden das
aber noch wirksam ist bei der impfquote
kommen wir offenbar mit den mildesten
mitteln nicht mehr weiter obwohl ja der
englisch impfstoff zur verfügung steht
in ausreichendem maße liegt die
impfquote in deutschland nur bei 68,4
prozent
die fdp hat ja die impfpflicht bisher
abgelehnt nun schlecht marco buschmann
der designierte justizminister vor diese
also die impfpflicht zur abstimmung im
bundestag frei frei zu geben warum sagen
sie nicht einfach die impfpflicht
auszuschließen war ein fehler der tunnel
das kommt darauf an wann unter welchen
voraussetzungen eine diskussion führt im
sommer diesen jahres hatten alle auch
ich persönlich die hoffnung dass wir
sehr schnell zu einer impfquote kommen
die es uns erlaubt im winter
die dinge wieder freizugeben die wir
alle schätzen und lieben das kulturleben
einkaufen die gleichen mehr leider haben
wir diese importe nicht erreichen und
deswegen müssen wir jetzt im winter eine
diskussion führen die uns erlaubt die
nächsten wellen zu brechen aber eine
impfpflicht werde jetzt nicht die
maßnahme die in diesem winter noch die
vierte welle bricht die diskussion über
eine impfpflicht muss jetzt geführt
werden damit wir gegebenenfalls im
späten winter oder im frühjahr nächsten
jahres eine entscheidung treffen können
und dann muss er eine impfpflicht wenn
sie denn kommen sollte sektoral also
berufsbezogen tätigkeit bezogen
einrichtungs bezogen oder gar allgemein
auch die diskussion wird er bereits
geführt muss ja auch durchgeführt werden
logistisch das heißt das hilft uns erst
im nächsten winter im winter 22 23 und
deswegen sollten wir uns mit aller
ernsthaftigkeit
diskussion öffnen sie öffentlich führen
mit experten in den fraktionen in den
parteien im deutschen bundestag damit
auch die menschen die noch vorbehalte
haben gegen eine impfung sehen dass wir
diese diskussion ernsthaft unter
einbeziehung aller argumente und
gegenargumente entführen zum schluss
noch herr thoma war es hören sie aus den
ampel fraktionen nächste woche ist ja
sitzungswoche des deutschen bundestages
wird das gerade veränderte
infektionsschutzgesetz noch mal
aufgeschnürt und modelliert im hinblick
auf differenzierte auch möglicherweise
strengere maßnahmen
ich werde dafür jetzt erst einmal die
heutige entscheidung aus karlsruhe
abzuwarten in aller ruhe zu studieren zu
analysieren und daraus die schlüsse zu
ziehen was wir nicht wollen sind
maßnahmen die das knie gebrochen werden
sind schüsse aus der hüfte sondern wir
sollten alle maßen namen evidenzbasiert
auf der grundlage einer angemessenen
ernsthaften diskussion treffen das
erwarte ich auch von unserer künftigen
regierungen und deswegen kommt jetzt
erst mal darauf an was wir heute aus
karlsruhe hören werden stephan thomae
war das der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
bundestagsfraktion ich sage danke für
ihre zeiten einen interessanten tag noch
nach berlin